[Applaus]
herzlich herzlich willkommen meine Damen und
Herren zu meiner Kochshow Söder sidet im ZDF
oder in der Wiederholung in ihrem schwartencenter
2sat ich habe mir heute einen Gast eingeladen der
Beweis dass ich ein total toleran der
Typ bin denn sie ist Moslem die Kübra
das ist falsch es heißt die seek im Kübra bei uns
immer den Nachnamen zuerst da weiß man gleich man
ist in der mental Provinz in Bayern dann lag
ich doch richtig wieso haben sie mich in ihre
Sendung eingeladen weil wir beide ein ähnliches
Schicksal teilen jetzt bin ich aber mal gespannt
wir beide teilen denselben Schmerz schauen
Sie unter den Hipstern in Berlin-Mitte bin
fühle ich mich als ganz normaler konservativer
fränkischer Fleischesser ein bisschen wie eine
grüne Behinderte Migrantin im Rollstuhl das
ist so schön jemand zu treffen der den Schmerz
nachvollziehen kann der weiß wie sich das anfühlt
als Außenseiter in der Gesellschaft also ich fühle
mich nur in ihrer Gesellschaft als Außenseiterin
sie sind ein Fleisch essender weißer heterosis man
sie sind die Mehrheit es ist richtig aber ich bin
ja auch Ministerpräsident das ist eine Minderheit
was wollen Sie denn Kochen ich zeige Ihnen heute
meine Rezept vor ein Volksauflauf also wie man
wie man den Volkszorn aufkocht und dann den Schaum
der Empörung abschöpft naja und dann präsentieren
sie sich als gütiger Landesvater auf dessen
Speisekarte für jeden Geschmack etwas dabei ist
so pfiffig werden wie sie dann sehe
ich links da wo ich immer schon sitzen
wollte vor einem Schweinebraten aber
gute Stichwort ich hätte schon mal
einen kleinen Gruß aus der Küche für
sie ist ein leckeres Schweinebraten
tut mir leid so etwas esse ich
nie ich bitte Sie nein leben
und nicht Schweinebraten macht
möglich sein aber nicht sinnvoll
sie meinen das Leben von 6 Millionen Muslimen
in Deutschland ist sinnlos richtig aber
das Leben ohne gicht ist auch möglich aber
schmerzlos welche Zutaten brauchen sie denn
für ihr Gericht natürlich brauchen Sie die
Basis für jede gute braune Soße und diese
Form ja zunächst mal müssen Sie eine furchtbare
Bedrohung behaupten es ist sowas hier jeder soll
essen was er will aber eine zwangshafte
veganisierung Deutschlands und Bayerns
macht keinen Sinn großartig und dann brauchen Sie
natürlich entschuldigen am besten die elide aber
gehören sie als bayerischer Ministerpräsident
nicht auch zu Eliten aus dem Lateinischen
eliäre das Binde meint eine Gruppe mächtiger
überdurchschnittlich qualifizierter Personen
zurück [Applaus]
gemein die sind natürlich die rot-grüne
Elite in Berlin die dovo Terroristen die
uns alle zwangsweise zu Veganern um
erzielen wollen so der erste Gang für
Sie in leckeren bayerischen Wurstsalat so bitte
lecker aus wer will denn
eigentlich Fleisch verwiesen
seines Ministeriums kein Fleisch mehr
servieren ja aber das ist ja der Anfang
ich war und dann geht es immer so weiter
die Grünen sagen wir sollen nur noch 10
Gramm Fleisch am Tag essen ich bitte Sie so
viel Fleisch bekommen sie gerade mal wenn Sie
ein Schwein ein Ohrloch sprechen da sind sie am
Nachmittag schon auf türkisch deswegen sage ich
werde den Anfängen für mich ist jedes
Kotelett gelebter an die verschiedenen
diese 10 Gramm kommen nicht von den Grünen das
war eine Beispielrechnung für Nachhaltigkeit von
der Deutschen Gesellschaft für Ernährung es
gab nie eine offizielle Empfehlung das hier
ist eine Gerüchteküche verstehen wir kochen hier
eine Bedrohung auf und dafür reicht manchmal nur
winziges Körnchen Wahrheit ja und dann rühren
sie da mächtig heiße Luft unter und dann geht
es ganze auf 4 1 zu fliegen außerdem hat er der
Präsident des Bayerischen Bauernverbandes gesagt
ne ist Fleisch fürs Klima und trinkt Milch
die ist nämlich CO2 neutral das wissen die
wenigsten ja weil die Kuh stößt ja nur das Zebra
zwei aus was in dem Gras war was sie fressen hat
wo haben Sie denn diese Milchmädchenrechnungen
von meinem Lieferanten aber keine solche der ist
regional das bedeutet den kennt irgendjemand
persönlich der Eckart Häuser vom Verband der
Milchwirtschaft Milchindustrie schauen Sie der
trinkt seine Milch sogar zur Currywurst großer
Gott das ist ja pervers und was trinkt er zu
seinem zarten Filet Düngemittel schön dass sie
langsam Appetit bekommen ich war aber Zeit für
das nächste Gericht so schauen Sie mal wunderbar
sondern auch sehr viel Soja für das
in Lateinamerika Regenwälder gerodet
werden und außerdem stoßen sie auch sehr
viel Methan aus das klimaschädlich ist
deswegen bedeutet konsequenter Klimaschutz
die Dinger möglichst schnell aufzuessen
natürliches Recht auf Darmkrebs richtig und dafür
kämpfe ich bis zum letzten fleischpflanzen so
jetzt brauchen wir natürlich noch ein bisschen
mehr schaffe und das ist die Behauptung dass
wir uns sofort wären müssen deswegen diese
groteskenschilder auf den Demos stoppt den
denn wacht eigentlich auf wenn sie so einen
Quatsch auf propressplakaten lesen dann wissen
sie dass ihre Soße die richtige Würze hat aber die
wird doch dann irgendwann kalt das schmeckt doch
dann nicht mehr immer wieder aufgekocht und zwar
immer mit saisonalen Zutaten verfeinert wieso nein
verstehe und pünktlich zu Weihnachten behaupten
wie die politisch korrekten die Weihnachtsmärkte
abschaffen zu wollen und durch wintermärkte
ersetzen was war denn noch mal der Unterschied
zwischen Weihnachten und Winter und dann will uns
die Woge Elite in Berlin wie das Böllern verbieten
damit ihr Laktose hintereinander sich nicht
ins Fell machen aber womit sollen wir uns denn
sonst die Finger zerspringen ich merke ich kommen
langsam in den Flo und irgendwann fordert jemand
dass der Osterhase abgeschafft wird weil der erst
einmal nachschauen soll oder überhaupt noch Eier
hat und dann wird die Grünen verzichte blase
ihn durch die Oster Weinbergschnecke ersetzen
und irgendwann behauptet jemand dass Jesus
eigentlich kein weißer war sondern Pius sie
und deswegen alle kurze fixe in den bayerischen
Amtsstuben geändert werden müssen vergangen
[Applaus]
was dann war das ja alles ganz umsonst
vielleicht wissen unsere Zuschauer
auch selbst wo sie abonnieren können
das jetzt noch zwei weitere Videos gucken
können stimmt unsere Zuschauer sind ja sehr klug